i think people think prenups are for
like only the kardashians no
like this is for moving forward it
involves kids it involves finances
involve kids
dozens kids won't be inaudible prenup
prenup will have will
involve setting forth how you want to
treat your property and your earnings
after marriage
it can involve child custody can't
involve child support because you don't
know what you're going to be making and
you can't contract for that because
that's not
your right that's the kids right we're
not talking about kids in a prenup
but you can talk about anything i make i
want to keep as my separate property
right i've been
i've been a comedian and an actor for
several years and i've
made who i am and i don't think that
just because i go now make another show
he should be entitled to half of it
right off the bat that doesn't make
sense to me but
i'm willing to put 50 of everything i
make
into a joint account so that 50 percent
of everything i make can be kind of the
things we grow and move from
i'm willing to gift a portion of the
house i own every year to him that we
stay together
and you can also put testamentary things
was that the word you were thinking of
definitely not i definitely did not know
that word if if you're marrying someone
that's a lot older or younger and one
person might die first you can put in
there that because you can always change
your will
but you can't change your prenup so you
got the guy waiting
whoa whoa
you can't change your prenup after
you've you you can if you both agree
but let's say the guy has a will and the
will says i'm going to give everything
to my
lovely wife she's been so wonderful for
35 years
and then in like a year you know the
last year he maybe
falls ill he's in the hospital he's got
this super hot poisonous tina
caretaker and all of a sudden at the
last minute on his own he gives
everything to her
okay you can do that but if you write a
prenup that says no matter what happens
i'm giving at least 25 to my lovely wife
that can't be changed yes or unless the
wife came in does that happen a lot like
at the buzzer death bed what
yeah people get nuts so this is what's
so fascinating to me is like
you're an incredibly like your job is to
be incredibly
factual literal with people that are
incredibly emotional
yes and again it's it what's interesting
to me and why i've been doing it for so
long is it's
super interesting so you get like
bankers and financial
geniuses and then you get actors and
then you get
football players and then you get rock
stars all these people that you think
are like
invincible unstoppable have everything
in the world
and then they're just like vulnerable
and cuddles like help me help me know
everything about them i know
how much pubic hair they have i don't
need to but they need to tell me this
information i know
we're crying and they're snot and like
in the middle of the night
and then it's over and i never see them
again like i'm at a restaurant and i
have like i get laid across the room
like
hey yeah which is fine because like i
learned early on like you i represent
the worst time of their life and the
most they can do is be like dude
she got me out of it she's awesome how
much of your job is like
emotionally placating people and how
much
a lot a lot but also imagine
most of my clients are in therapy
therapists are like even the really good
ones three or four hundred dollars an
hour
crazy i'm 9.50 and i'm a hot mess you're
9.50 an hour
i wasn't married this is gonna be a
short podcast guys i normally go four
hours
it took me an hour to get it i was like
where's woodland hills i don't
understand i i grew up in a thousand
dollars just to get her here
it's how expensive laura wasser is
incredible
so yeah i mean there's there's there's a
lot of the emotional but there's also if
you're a good family law attorney you
can draw the line and be like look
i'm not your friend we're not gonna have
this is the line together and talk about
your next boyfriend
that is for your friends or your mom or
your sister or your therapist
i can apply the facts of your situation
and i can also tell you hey
i've been doing this for 25 years this
too shall fucking pass
we're gonna get you through this you
will be okay what's the biggest mistake
you see people consistently make over
and over again when they come into your
office
thinking with their you know not making
business decisions this is a business
decision that you're making getting
married is a business decision
as is getting divorced wow yes it is
because you can love someone forever
but you can't always be married to them
forever that's right and love goes in
and out lust goes in and out yes
like goes in and out like i was like i
will always love you
i do not like you right now it's like
the the people that i follow on
instagram the people i love the most
sometimes i gotta mute
yeah for some you know sometimes i had
to mute you you know and
um do you ever feel have people come in
your office that you're like this is
premature
you're this is irrational yes you should
stay in this yes
and i have seen people do you feel like
people are too like have you noticed
over your
uh uh career people being too quick to
get divorced
these days no
here's why yeah because it's very
expensive to hire me
yeah not too quick however i i think you
know i have an online divorce website
yes
we will have a lot of people you're
making it too easy to get divorced
we will have are you why the divorce
rate is so high
no but that has really skyrocketed over
the pandemic
whereas our firm is pretty much we're
always busy it's always consistent we
don't have more calls i think
actually people have gotten closer
during the pandemic and reestablished
family values and how it works and
i've seen a lot of families where
dad might be the breadwinner and mom
might be the stay-home mom
and yet dad's now doing cooking a couple
nights a week and
dad might be more you know i love that
remote learning with the kids
the pandemic has been so funny to me
because um
all my guy friends have called me and
it's made them realize how much
their wives do yes like
they're home all day i'm home all day
with the kid and i'm cooking i have to
make breakfast lunch and dinner it's
like yeah women have been doing this
all this time yep just fyi the pandemic
like
like all my guy friends like my wife is
like a superhero she's just
done this every day the working moms
that were already working
and now i mean we do that both because
when i say like stay home parent
for whatever reason a lot of the times
the dads are like well where's the nanny
yeah like what i'm the nanny
yeah i remember i'm uh uh who was i was
talking to a friend of mine
and the dad uh said something about uh
their kid and was like oh well we need
to get
someone to um i i don't have time to
babysit the kid and she goes it's not
babysitting you're
it's your kid it doesn't it's not
babysitting it's called parenting
right and you're not doing me any favors
yeah no you don't get points for that
yeah what i'm saying like parenting is i
think that has changed a bit
during this thing i wonder what will
happen afterwards
do you feel like more people are
breaking up
because of the pandemic or people are
hunkering down
you know what beginning i was saying i
think people were breaking up i think
the prospect of doing this now i think
the ones that have stayed have hunkered
down i mean we'll see i think it's an
interesting time it's an interesting
reevaluation of your relationship i mean
my i have different relationships with
my friends than i used to have so true
so true i it really is like
are you worth dying for yeah those are
the friends i talked to i'm like
even are you worth being uncomfortable
for yeah i mean i don't yeah i don't
like you enough to sit six feet away in
the cold i mean
i i like you but i don't want to hang
out you're like huh
like i i don't like you enough to listen
to you through a mask
right right like you're not entertaining
enough
to like have to do this it's true and
and it makes you think and or
or even going out i mean we couldn't for
a while now we can't so like you know i
used to go out three or four nights
a week yeah i go out like one night a
week and i'm still like god that
telenovela
and netflix i'm really into it is anna
gonna have the baby or not
do you um get annoyed like yes i was
thinking